[Music]
on this Monday night back to school but
not back to normal a new reality means
new rules for some young Quebec students
we have hand-washing stations the plan
getting an A from some parents and an F
from others some Ontario stores reopen
their doors we're just really excited
honestly but it's not business as usual
contact tracing why it's key to safely
getting back to business your employer
is paying for your time they are have
information but privacy concerns persist
and politics and business the balancing
act as the federal government announces
a new lifeline for big companies
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with a dilemma playing out
across the country how to safely begin
easing the restrictions we're all living
with Quebec and Ontario both made moves
today to inch back to a new normal
even though Quebec has the most cases
and the most deaths in Canada primary
schools and daycares reopened in Quebec
today though only outside Montreal
attendance is not mandatory and strict
physical distancing rules are in place
Montreal is still shut down it remains
the epicenter of Canada's kovat 19
outbreak of the 85 new deaths reported
in Quebec today 82 were in the Montreal
area premier France while ago calls the
situation in that city very fragile and
says he will push the planned date of
reopening there beyond May 25th if
necessary the Prime Minister was asked
today whether he thinks some provinces
are moving too fast that the sacrifices
we've all made for the past two months
could all go up in smoke
if we move too quickly on reopening or
if a given jurisdiction makes the wrong
decisions that's why being cautious and
gradual and vigilant is essential in
Ontario thousands of employees went back
to work today we'll get to that in just
a moment but we begin in Quebec and Mike
Armstrong on how many parents were
willing to send their kids back to class
principal Melanie primo was on the
sidewalk to welcome students back but
the buses that pulled up were almost
empty only three kids on this one and
only three on this one as well parents
had been asked to register if their kids
would be returning so primo says she
knew what to expect and knew it wouldn't
be many 35 I would say 33 as of now out
of a hundred and 70 those low numbers at
Howick elementary are fairly typical
according to the school board it had six
schools reopened Monday with about 20%
attendance health officials have said it
safe but even parents who did drop off
their children were nervous you have to
weigh at all it's all it's a personal
choice so it's hard it's it's really
hard to decide
such a beautiful classroom the school
put out a video to reassure parents and
students last week it outlined what to
expect in terms of precautions hand
sanitizer staggered recess physical
distancing and a new addition to the
school day every two hours a bell or
announcement will go over the intercom
and in intervals everybody will wash
their hands a few times through the day
now attendance in some areas was higher
Quebec City saw about two-thirds of kids
returned but schools in the Montreal
region are still closed are not supposed
to reopen until May 25th and there's
pushback the city is the worst-hit area
in the country critics questioned
whether it's too early to send kids back
the premier insists he's not rushing
anything we still have two weeks in
front of us and if this situation is not
getting better in the next two weeks
we'll postpone the province is going to
watch the schools that reopen very
closely monitoring for kovat 90 note
breaks but they're also going to watch
how children not in school are doing and
the mental health impact that might be
having Mike Armstrong Global News
Montreal we are tracking case numbers
closely tonight as Canada approaches
more pandemic milestones the number of
confirmed cases in this country is now
nearly 17,000 nearly five thousand
people have died there are some positive
signs in the numbers though more than
40% of those who have tested positive in
Canada have recovered and daily case
numbers are trending downward in most
parts of the country a number of
provinces had no new cases today while
in Ontario there were 308 new cases that
does represent a slowdown though over
the past few weeks and today thousands
of people in Ontario went back to work
as some retail stores were allowed to
reopen Eric Sorenson explains the
strategy in that province and the
pitfalls that lie ahead retailers across
Ontario with Street access have been
allowed to reopen among them the common
people shop a small general store in
Toronto we're just really excited
honestly to be able to see some of our
regulars and see some of the new people
who may have heard about our business
they joined garden centers and bigger
businesses already open
provincial and other parks have also
opened ahead of schedule all a welcome
sight after eight weeks of closures it's
a good thing it's showing us that all
the work that you've done with social
distancing is paying off and it's good
for mental health the premier hopes it's
the right direction with strict public
health measures in place today thousands
of people are going back to work
thousands of people are earning a
paycheck again small business leaders
are pleased to see more options for
Canadians it hasn't made sense to us
that we send all of their consumers to
the same big-box stores
rather than spreading them out over the
thousands of thousands of tiny companies
that are lucky to see maybe 10 or 20
customers in a day
still the economic lock down required
unprecedented government spending
Ontario's financial Accountability
Office forecasts the provincial deficit
will grow from about 10 billion dollars
to 41 billion for the next year and
reopening only gradually could see the
deficit deepened further even more
fiscal stimulus will be required so even
even with the big numbers that we have
today I suspect that we still aren't
done hearing about new programs to help
stimulate a recovery meantime there is a
steady improvement in the kovat 19
picture in Ontario there's a lag time in
counting but Monday's 308 new cases
shows a promising trend of declining
numbers in the province
health officials point out that a
long-term lockdown wouldn't be healthy
either we need to get life by starting
to go back to normal but obviously this
is going to result in some increase in
the number of cases and we have to be
ready for that but it's important to
note that that is expected restrictions
are being eased but it's also clear the
economy is not stampeding towards
business as usual Eric Sorenson Global
News Toronto even when the curve
completely flattens it doesn't mean the
virus has vanished so returning to work
in school will require constant
vigilance if there's an outbreak it will
have to be contained immediately that
means tracing all the people anyone who
tests positive has come into contact
with companies are busy deploying a wide
range of technologies and protective
measures to help keep their staff and
customers safe but at what
cost Jeff simple reports for the first
time in weeks this Toronto business is
back in bloom Ontario garden centers are
now allowed to open their doors to the
public but when employees arrived they
barely recognized it it is
extraordinarily different besides
keeping their distance staff are
required to wear protective equipment
and some companies are even adding
surveillance this auto plant opened its
doors to workers for the first time in
nearly two months there now scanned by
thermal imaging cameras taking their
temperature before they're allowed in
even in the break arias we've provided
separation and barriers but what if an
employee tests positive for kovat 19
turns out there's an app for that
private companies and governments in
more than 25 countries have now deployed
these contact tracing smartphone apps
they use a phone's GPS to track a
person's location so for example if a
co-worker were to test positive for
kovin 19 the company could retrace their
steps and alert anyone who they might
have had contact with it's important to
kind of note that all of this remains
anonymous this Vancouver app developer
says his software also helps companies
in force physical distancing let's say
for example best practices is you only
allowed to have one person in a truck at
a time on a construction site and be
seems like there are two people in the
truck we might send a notification but
these location tracking kovat 19 apps
are raising alarm bells if you start
collecting to your location data you're
gonna lose a lot of faith in this time
trust because that can then be linked to
personal identifiers Ontario's former
Privacy Commissioner notes that Apple
and Google are teaming up on a solution
to support contact tracing with
Bluetooth technology instead of GPS to
better protect personal data but while
government's must persuade their
citizens to use the software employers
don't need to ask employers are allowed
to know where their employees are on
what their employees are doing because
the employer is the one paying for the
employees time health experts say these
protective measures
including contact tracing are critical
if the country is to avoid a second wave
and turn over a new leaf
Jeff simple Global News Toronto a second
Cargill meat processing plant has shut
down in Canada this one near Montreal
sixty-four employees tested positive for
Kovan 19 a week ago Cargill reopened its
plant in High River Alberta which had
the largest outbreak in the country more
than 900 workers there tested positive
and there's pressure on the American
owned company to explain why workers
aren't being kept safe heather Eurex
west explains a month after an outbreak
among hundreds of workers at Cargill
High River meat processing plant the
company is facing another outbreak and
another shutdown
the plant is about to close temporarily
because while its apprehensive a measure
we want to test all the employees the
shawbly facility is the third Cargill
owned plant that we know of to be
impacted by kovat 19 its High River
Alberta facility closed in mid-april
after an outbreak there made more than
900 workers sick two workers have now
died there has also been an outbreak in
a facility in Fort Morgan Colorado at
least 56 workers have tested positive
one person has died but that plant has
never closed the decision to close the
Chamblee Quebec plant came after 64
workers tested positive I would say that
right now Cargill wouldn't be on top of
my list of companies that have managed
very well Cargill has faced criticism
for failing to close the High River
plant sooner before the outbreak there
grew to become one of the largest in
North America and Alberta occupational
health and safety report also found the
company excluded the Union from an
investigation until how the virus was
allowed to spread the company has been
given more time to complete its
investigation but the Quebec facility is
closing now before a few dozen cases can
become a hundred or more the company
will eventually be able to resume its
activities after a certain period of
confinement all those employees in a
statement to Global News Cargill says
it's continually changing and improving
how it responds to outbreaks in order to
protect employees
anyone required to take time off to
isolate will be given up to 80 hours
paid leave and will not be allowed back
at work until their symptom free Heather
Europe's West Global News Calgary the
federal government is offering a new
package to support big businesses
struggling to survive it's not described
as a bailout it's an emergency financing
plan for companies and nonprofit
organizations with annual revenue of 300
million dollars or more there are
exceptions banks are not eligible for
example nor are companies that pay their
executives excessive salaries but a
whole range of companies could be
eligible from Airlines to retailers to
the oil and gas sector there are some
strings attached strings that are as
much about politics as business our
chief political correspondent David akin
is here to explain David that's right
it's called the large enterprise
emergency finance facility le e FF leaf
they've been working on it for a couple
of weeks and all the while there's been
a battle inside the Liberal caucus as to
whether or not to help out the oil and
gas sector some led by heritage Minister
in Quebec MP Stephen Gebo have argued
it's time to let the fossil fuel
industry die but Deputy Prime Minister
Chrystia Freeland and Finance Minister
Bill Morneau have led the fighting
cabinet to provide more help for the
energy sector so with the leaf oil and
gas firms we'll be able to access
federal financing that's important to
Freeland and Morneau but those firms
will have to demonstrate commitment to
some environment and climate change
goals and that's important to get Bo and
his camp and all corporations getting
leaf funding we'll also have to agree to
restrictions on executive compensation
for NGO dividends and share buybacks and
agree to honor collective agreements and
Pensions now those conditions are
important as well to the NDP and the
bloc québécois on remember this is a
liberal minority government that its
survival is going to depend on the help
of a third party Donna David there's a
lot of details still to come what's the
early reaction though from businesses is
there a willingness to take up this
offer well the early reaction from
corporate Canada is okay good start
there's definitely more details needed
and there's going to be a transparency
issue will taxpayers get to know the
details of each loan arrangement with
each firm and all those firms will
they're worried that those details are
going to be disclosed so that is going
to be a barrier to take up Donna all
right David akin in Ottawa thanks now to
nova scotia the RCMP intend to conduct
what they call a psychological autopsy
on the gunman who killed 22 people it
will examine his past behavior and
interactions with others police have
spoken with more than 500 witnesses
already they're looking to speak with
anyone who may have had past conflict
with the gunman among the other details
released today RCMP say he had four
firearms when he fled the town of Porter
pick where the rampage began the night
of April 18th two were semi-automatic
rifles and two were semi-automatic
handguns the RCMP did not release the
make or the caliber one of the guns was
traced to Canada the other three came
from the United States investigators
have also identified the business that
produced the decals the gunmen used to
make his car look like a real RCMP
cruiser the decals they say were not
made with the permission of the business
owner the gunmen drove that replica
police car for much of the 14 hour
rampage and more a real RCMP uniform 22
people were killed including RCMP
constable Heidi Stephenson
there was a somber procession along Nova
Scotia's Highway of Heroes today the
body of one of six Canadian Armed Forces
members killed in a helicopter crash
last month was brought home 23 year old
sub left 10 and Abigail Cobra was a
marine systems engineer on HMCS
Fredericton all six on board the cyclone
helicopter were killed when it went down
in the Ionian Sea off the coast of
Greece on April 29th the remains of only
two have been found the cause of the
crash is under investigation stopping
the spread in the West Wing coming up
what's being done to protect the
American president's inner circle plus
South Korea's cluster of new cases after
attempting to reopen
you
at the White House in Washington Kovac
19 is now hitting close to home two
staffers have tested positive and
several people on the coronavirus task
force are now self isolating as Jackson
prosecco reports if the virus can reach
one of the most secure buildings in the
world what does it mean for the rest of
the country all the security in the
world couldn't stop kovat 19 from
penetrating the White House potentially
exposing the president and vice
president
it could happen it's the hidden enemy
remember that it's the hidden enemy so
things happen Trump and his staff are
given daily coronavirus tests after the
vice president's press secretary and the
president's personal valet tested
positive there was a rush to trace
anyone the two people had contact with
testing is important too to quickly
detect an outbreak and to contain an
outbreak members of the coronavirus task
force including dr. Anthony foul she
went into a modified quarantine as a
precaution the Vice President declined
to isolate but rapid testing and tracing
is largely unavailable to most Americans
last week the president also suggested
it isn't needed this is why the whole
concept of tests aren't necessarily in
an admission of vulnerability the White
House is now asking staff other than the
president to wear face masks muddling
the message as Trump insists the virus
is under control and states should
reopen I think it points to the fact
that all businesses need to be careful
and by the way they need updated
guidance from our Centers for Disease
Control and Prevention to ensure that
they create a workplace that is as safe
as possible polls show most Americans
were already worried about the risks of
reopening too quickly if the virus can
spread here it can spread anywhere
Jackson prosto Global News Washington
ahead a dreadful feeling of deja vu the
coronavirus Reimer jizz in wuhan
you are watching global national
[Music]
there are new cases of kovat 19 reported
in Wuhan China the first since lifting
the ten-week locked down there five new
cases were recorded in Wuhan all of them
live in the same residential compound
and they were asymptomatic meaning they
tested positive for the virus but we're
not exhibiting any clinical symptoms
like cough or fever health authorities
have warned that as countries emerge
from strict lock downs arise in
infections like this is likely South
Korea fears it could be on the cusp of a
second wave it has scrapped plans to
reopen schools this week after a cluster
of new cases linked to the Capitals
nightclub district 85 recent cases are
connected to bars and nightclubs popular
with the LGBTQ community in Seoul and
all are linked to one man who is bar
hopping authorities are contact tracing
thousands of people who may have been to
those bars and clubs but there's been
some reluctance to that some people in
the gay community prefer anonymity and
fear of backlash from South Korea's
relatively conservative society and in
Germany cases are rising just as
lockdown measures there are easing
Germany recorded 357 new cases today
bringing the total number in that
country to nearly a hundred and seventy
thousand gyms did reopen over the
weekend in places like restaurants
museums and shopping malls reopened last
week physical distance and measures are
still in place but the reproduction rate
for the virus in Germany shows that it
is now spreading exponentially next
serenity now remembering a man who made
us all laugh
I'm saying you wanna be should we drop
you like a bag of dirt do you want a
piece of me you gotta it was a TV dad
like no other comedian Jerry Stiller has
passed away after a career going back
more than six decades he was best known
for his role on Seinfeld as George
Costanza 'he's father Frank a role that
made him the father of Festivus and at
the Festivus dinner you gather your
family around and tell them all the ways
they have disappointed you over the past
year and his their dream no instead
there's a full requires no decoration I
find tinsel distracting Stiller spent
nine years on the popular TV show the
king of queens his last acting credit
was in 2016 alongside his son Ben
Stiller in the sequel to the hit movie
Zoolander Jerry Stiller was 92 his
family says he died of natural causes
and that is global national for this
Monday I'm Donna freezin this is
national nursing week and we leave you
tonight with a tribute to nurses and
other essential workers in Paris the
base of the Eiffel Tower lit up with
portraits of frontline workers from
doctors and nurses to shop workers and
teachers who have kept working while
others stayed home the message is simple
thankfully you were there take care of
yourselves bye-bye
[Music]
you